yes everything about this is normal me
and my BAE's hey guys welcome to
Saturday re if you don't know said it
varies a look back in my week and vlog
for him yeah right now we're on the
shoot for Electra woman and Dyna girl
the series that Hannah and I did in the
beginning of the year we're shooting
still photos for it though but let's
take a look back all the things that
I've gone into this week
behind-the-scenes of book on
I ran back to bookcon to moderate a
panel for abigail breslin me that little
girl from Little Miss Sunshine she's a
woman she wrote a book and I'm gonna
moderate a panel on it panel no just a
Q&A discussions just me and her
it's great my sister broke the rule and
she was shaving her legs and my mom
walked in she had one Sunday we're
driving down to Philly welcome to
backstage at a Philadelphia show we got
all the seating options available we got
water skis focus and we got Holy Trinity
family portraits oh my god this beauty
you look very phallic maybe when it's
only wide if we are done the VIP meet up
on the [ __ ] up [ __ ] oh look at the
greatest security guards about that
honest about wanting to get the good
morning for diary
it is Monday it is the morning after a
Philadelphia no filter show can you tell
oh not feeling good I didn't sleep very
much at all last night
last night after the show I ran back to
watch the grace Helbig show on E the new
time 11 o'clock on Sunday the episode
was so great with Adam Devine and Jack
Black and I ran back to watch episode so
I could live tweet with you guys and
then I ordered food off of a 24 and then
they called me and said two of the
things I ordered they didn't actually
have and so I just cancelled the order
and then went down and had drinks with
Hannah memory dependin time got away and
ended up just ordering room service and
it wanted a cheesesteak and wings at
like 2:00 a.m. then my stomach just did
not agree with me all night so I didn't
sleep very much but it's ok it's 11:45
right now I'm getting stuff done
and we get in a car to drive to Newark
Airport to go home to Los Angeles and to
see goose the dog I have treats for her
from you guys first of all thank you to
all the audiences in New York and
Chicago and Philadelphia for really
great shows especially last night I had
so many family members there and my mom
it's her birthday today actually and we
got to sing happy birthday to her at the
show and she just had a great time is
that all I wanted to say I believe that
that is all I wanted to say oh but right
now I'm waiting on some dumplings
debating whether that's a good idea or
not because I had to go get in the car
with Hannah for like two hours yeah
someone's doing outdoor tasks
this is my dog goose did a ball go down
into that weird ghost hole not only
she's my dog she's my style I come thank
you to the girl on tour they gave us
this um today's an easy day it's Tuesday
and I am on a mission to finally put
this together just do it it's time to
run errands aka I'm giving myself a
reason to go to Target
I need hangers let's do it close later
in the day I forget that I snapchat some
things and then I don't record them here
and so I don't know where the story line
actually lies but there's a new road and
just to give you some closure if you
were so scared of how the progress went
earlier its I did that I put that
together now off to see San Andreas the
rock after I dry my hair
hi guys happy Wednesday it is Wednesday
I just uploaded my video earlier today
it's a Father's Day gift card which is
very obvious by me pointing to my
breasts with my name on it
and it's a very lazy day to say which is
like so needed and so wonderful and so
what I'm doing is I have this room that
I kind of work out of sometimes and I'm
rearranging it like all girls do I'm
putting these weird cotton thing of all
things up that I got and this thing is
down here getting makeup done for this
episode of Oscars hotel look who's here
Mitchell Davis is here this is will be
me Mitchell Davis just did a Jay Z
impression and it was like surprisingly
pretty good yeah it was caught on camera
not this camera unfortunately but
another camera so just get ready guys
submit to the Kickstarter oh my god
let's rant about Beyonce and
when your sprite n goes wrong we're on
lunch for Oscars hotel and I said to
come back to the dress room and they
gave me just to take just a second and
show and look flowers oh yeah I'm
playing a character that it's an aloof
hermit crab
hello happy Saturday we're on set
shooting photos of election one diner
girl we're back and look there's Dyna
girl except Dyna girl hurt her foot real
bad Mike's here gang's all here
it's a really exciting day and they're
getting Hannah
the only strap on Hannah ever wears ha
ha I regret that wow that was great
thanks for watching guys so great to
subscribe leave a comment down below
about what you're thinking right now
like this video cuz that's fun to do it
doesn't take much physical effort I
trust in this look at that
I don't know very power much hero